oui mon père m'en sont tombés
je crois que c'est quand j'ai les crues
de claquer mallet avait vraiment changé
beaucoup physiquement et que je
m'interroge sur ce physique voilà et qui
ont évidemment autour du limbourg est
alors j'ai arrêté
[Musique]
on perd en revanche ça a été une mission
qui a été fait après tout la polémique
qu'on a connu et la mère avoue cyril et
deschamps a vu les accusations
d'homophobie et par l'ambiance des
pénétrantes pas c'est pas du tout dans
les chocs d'invités qu'on a eu pour moi
c'est que ça reste quand même
polnareff
c'est une bonne d'arc 1 ce soir lors de
la tombola qui vient de me dire qu'est
ce qu'ils manient pas ce qu'est une
bonne d'arc à ce soir vous êtes trop
bien sûr alors ce soir c'est dark à ce
remarquable chez cedar cas et on fait
des dar k et débarque à zéro race rare
que des dards cas c'est baba wapala pas
comme ça s'il est à ses débuts comme
aucun fait démarre exactement ont fait
que des dark avec michel polnareff en
soi mais en réalité dans le genre
légende un peu vivante encore 118
[Musique]